so sister Jazelle Subhan Allah she
called in to ask a question on behalf of
her husband who's a Muslim she's a
Catholic married to him uh and she they
asked a question pertaining to TWI and
Subhan Allah um not only that her
husband ordered this guided prayer mat
he knows how to pray now he doesn't need
this anymore and I asked her a question
I said um would your husband would be
able to teach you how to pray Salah if
you accept Islam and she was like yes is
that correct yes sister are you ready to
accept Islam yes but before before I do
that I just want to make to make it
clear that I
will join Islam not because I want to be
rewarded not because I want my sins to
be
um uh wiped away I am joining it because
I just imagine the people back in the
day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years
what is one thing that they would carry
with them the Quran why because they did
not have it on their mobile devices or
their gadgets brothers and sisters
imagine you have a app the Quran app
which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on your that you read it wherever
you was let's go to the next caller
please okay we
have Salam alikum
Candi hi hello where are you calling
from I well thank you for actually
calling me candy but my real name is
jizelle um and I am calling from
Winnipeg
Manitoba where from Winnipeg
Manitoba what is that where is that
hanada Canada oh wow okay M how's how's
the weather there I don't know by the
way that are multikills you keep amazing
with information from yes yes what's
your question like random things he will
know things I don't
know okay so I
yes my husband is a revert and right now
he has um caffeine withdrawal so I
called to ask questions on his
behalf what what what does he
have caffeine withdrawal
Caff with
okay what's that what's that caffeine
withraw he's not stopping caffeine yeah
okay okay because um of
Ramadan Mah okay yeah okay um how how's
he feeling is he
okay uh yes he's he's managing he's not
grumpy that's goodd so what's what's his
question he wants to ask if he can have
coffee no I know that he can't even if
he tells me I'm going to say nope um so
my it seems that he it seems that you
are you know you're you're controlling
alhamdulillah this at least this side
which is good that's not bad um yes
okay um all right so my first question
or his question is um it has um about
Twi and if a person has trouble praying
um T we standing up um and I know that
he um there's an option for to sit down
while doing it um how this one pray T
sitting down so when he pray T he has to
sit down on the floor like this is that
you need to know firstly that the Mand
prayer the prayer he has to pray them he
has to pray it standing up unless if he
has some serious problems then he can
sit down otherwise he has to pray
standing this for yeah the mandator
prayer the is volunt prayer if he prayed
standing he will have the full reward if
he prayed sitting we'll have half reward
so that's why it's okay for someone to
sit down but he has to be on the floor
not on a chair many people they think
the chair is the option you go to the
chair option unless if you have problems
in your knees you cannot sit on the
floor then you go to the chair option
otherwise you sit down on the floor you
just be normal sitting down so when the
Imam is bowing for Ru you bow a bit like
this and then when you go to Su you go
full sujud on the floor then it is
permissible for the person to do that
for the and the voluntary prayer so the
voluntary prayer the person is entit to
pray the to pray standing or sitting
down and standing is better but the
mandatory prayer that has to be prayed
standing unless if the person has an
illness that prevents him from standing
then he can sit down is that clear your
question may Allah how long you been a
Muslim sister how long you been a Muslim
oh I'm I'm actually not a
Muslim um but my husband is a
revert and why don't you become a
Muslim oh um that's a heavy question
um a heavy question but there can be a
light answer like taking the sh okay um
well I'm I'm a cathol Catholic
um I am a spiritual Catholic uh I have
stopped believing in the human side of
it sorry other Catholic listeners um
yeah
I oh wait my heart is um I'm nervous uh
F it's fine sister look I feel guilty
yes car on yeah carry
on I feel
guilty of switching um
because well Catholics I think we were
born to feel guilty but um I'm just
worried that if
I choose or if I become a revert that
I'm not really sure that um I will be
punished because I'm I'm saying no it's
like I'm I'm turning my back
away from from let me tell you something
sister yeah you know the the the the for
example the faith that you are in for
example the catholism
now think about it what Jesus was Jesus
a
Catholic for example uh for example did
he believe in the cross that's another
thing you see the point so if he didn't
know that how he's going to be killed or
suppose this yeah and if he as well he
was asking and begging God not to be
killed all of these things it tells you
something we believe in Jesus peace be
upon him but as a prophet and messenger
of God he's not God he cannot be God and
as when we say about God God is all
knowing all powerful has independent
will and none of these ones none of
these conditions applies to Jesus but it
fits him to be prophet and M of God and
actually he said a profound word when
the people of Israel they came around
him surrounding him saying to him uh you
know thinking about what he is and he
said oh you people of Israel our Lord is
one and he used the
term which is in Hebrew and that's this
term is exactly used by Moses peace be
upon him it's exactly in the same the
same word in the
Quran say Allah is one and unique there
is no second there's no third he is the
only one and he is the only one worthy
to be worshiped that is Islam and
actually by you believing in Islam and
accepting Islam you're not turning you
back to Jesus actually you are following
the way of Jesus he was saying he submit
his will to the will of God he said I'm
going to go to my father and your father
my God and your god he has a God he
prayed to God he prayed to God that's
how Muslims and actually you are
following the way and the methodology of
Jesus peace be upon him you are and you
are earning as well Muhammad peace be
upon him the last and the final
messenger and he was sent by Allah to
the people to guide the people to the to
the right path so basically when you are
accepting this you're not turning back
actually to Jesus rather than you are
following the path of Jesus pleas be
upon him and you follow the path of all
the prophets and Messengers does that
make sense to you sister yes it it does
um I also I'm a Filipino and in my
family
um Catholicism my my family beliefs
strongly in it and I am I feel um hes
well I I feel afraid
of the repercussions of of me um I
understand sister so what's what my
suggestion is if you become Muslim
yourself keep this between you and your
husband until when the time comes when
you feel confident to mention this to to
your family that's fine but at least
that do do the right thing do the right
decision at this moment
because because at the end of the life
is short you don't have to go to tell
them just do the right thing do the
right this and inside you you believe in
God inside you it makes sense to you
that Jesus is a prophet sent by God it
makes sense to you that Muhammad is the
last and the final messenger that's why
your husband embraced Islam and he's
going to be the most happy person that
when his wife when you and him both of
you became Muslim when both of you are
praying together fasting together doing
the righteous things and by the way the
background of the Filipinos if you go to
the history they were Muslims until the
Portuguese came there and the Spain came
Spain Spanish came there literally
forced the people to change their faith
from Islam because Filipino was like
Malawi as well they have kind of links
with the with Malaysian and Indonesian
and these areas and then they forced
them to change their F Faith that's why
they became Catholic otherwise in the
past they were Muslims in the past and
if you go in the history you might find
one of your ancestors was a Muslim Al
yes so the point is sister we are when
you are accepting Islam you are
not you back to
Jesus Islam does that make sense to you
sister yes um I just want to say thank
you for uh talking to me about it
although it wasn't my um uh my Reas
calling I'm watching you and that's yes
we're here in the Hall of Ramadan you
can call whenever you like if you change
your mind if you want to take your
shahada just knowing Catholicism you
know you have to go to the priest to ask
for forgiveness we believe in Islam like
the reason why we're here is because to
pra Salah that's what makes Islam so
different because we single out God In
Worship when we worship God and pray we
don't go to Muhammad Moses Jesus upon
them all we go to God directly that's
what makes Islam unique go to the IMs we
don't go to the imams to ask them for to
to forgive us and give them a 50 pound
note behind the thing so he can forgive
us faster like Amazon Prime so the thing
is here we go to God Almighty directly
we pray to him and you know if you
accept Islam my dear sister if you do we
will teach you how to pray Salah we have
our sister team who will teach you how
to pray Salah step by step you can go to
our website Salah plus.com and you can
order if you want sister I know already
because my husband has it and he
actually told me uh a couple of days ago
they said I can has got one of this has
he got one of this yes and he can pray
without um reading the prayers now see
this this is this is profound this is
profound look at this this is a sister
who's a Catholic her husband is a Muslim
who's a revert who ordered the guided
prayer mat and now can pray without
using it that means now he has he has
learned it sister get guess what if you
accept Islam that means your husband can
teach you how to pray is that correct
yes I know about that because he tells
he's been telling me a lot about Islam
and he also reads um the English
translation of
Quran this is what we say to the people
yeah W imagine her reverts uh husband
who's having a caffeine with J now he's
relaxing here
he he's having a CA withdraw yeah but
and he's got he's he's got an amazing
wife like this lady who's there trying
to help him yeah maybe listen to help
him about Islam trying to help him about
Islam by the way prac ask think about it
sorry sister we broke up the sorry yes I
was saying what's your
name my name is jel uh or you can call
me Jill okay so sister Jazelle Subhan
Allah she called in to ask a question on
behalf of her husband who's a Muslim
she's a Catholic married to him uh and
she they asked a question pertaining to
TWI and Subhan Allah um not only that
her husband ordered this guy to prayer
mat he knows how to pray now he doesn't
need this anymore and I asked her a
question said um would your husband
would be able to teach you how to pray
Salah if you accept Islam and she was
like yes is that correct yes Subhan
Allah my dear sister do you let me ask
you a question do you believe God is one
do you believe he is one
absolutely okay do you
believe do you believe he has Partners
do you believe there is more than one
God or there's just one God and he
cannot be a human
being there's only one God for me good
so you don't believe God is a man a
statue a tree an idol no no thank you so
my dear sister do you believe in
prophets do you believe in Jesus Moses
Abraham as
prophets yes do you believe the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him as a prophet
do you know anything yet still or yes um
um my he has been telling me a lot about
Muhammad um so yes I I believe
sister you you are a Muslim you can't be
a Catholic because you believe God is
one you don't believe God Is A Part has
a Partners he's not a human being you
believe the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him as a final messenger you are a
Muslim I mean your husband after he
comes off his caffeine withdrawal he can
teach you how to pray Salah not only
that sister I believe you should take
your shahada with us because you already
believe it you already believe God is
one I and I believe me I came to Islam
TW 11 years ago yeah this is my 11th
Ramadan and I always believe God is one
the moment I heard Christians believe
God is a human being he was done for me
I said I cannot follow this religion
because I do not believe God is a man so
my dear sister why don't you take your
shahada with us it's up to you we don't
want to force you I'm very careful with
this stuff I don't like forcing but it's
because it's Ramadan it's Ramadan sister
we can get you some dates I'm sure you
have dates you don't need dates here but
alhamdulillah you can fast learn how to
pray Salah and our sister's team will be
in contact with you if it's totally up
to you but why don't you take shahada
sister because you already believe well
it would definitely um be a fun one um
fasting with
Aaron um in it will be and not only that
you can pray with him sister yeah and
our sister's team at Salah plus will
help teach you how to pray Salah you
might not need your husband is there
yeah he just needs some caffeine and
he's he's good to go yeah you know what
I'll even send some coffee yeah inshah
can help some British
coffee why don't you if you're ready you
can repeat after us you can repeat after
Muhammed and you can take a shot are you
ready to accept Islam with us and insh
you can even do a marriage ceremony for
you and your uh
husband okay yeah yeah no I I just want
to say
I I feel very
um um sorry Aaron I told you I'm not
going to uh be too emotional but uh I
just want to say that um I feel
honored yeah alhamd that you are honored
that's why we are honored we are honored
actually so so my point sister to you
you you will be you will be in Islam you
start high all your previous sins will
be wife you will be like a newborn baby
with no sins and I will give you
something GL Tiding for you our Prophet
peace be upon him he said that those
ones who accept Isa or mssa peace be
upon both of them and he accept the
prophet sallallah Al Allah will reward
them twice which means that as soon as
we accepting Islam Allah will reward you
twice and Allah will replace all the
things that you used to do Allah will
replace them in reward in Islam so you
start sister are you ready to accept
Islam yes but before before I do that I
just want to make to make it clear that
I
will join Islam not because I want to be
rewarded not because I want my sins to
be
um uh wiped away I am joining it because
I want to because I choose to join and
because I believe in this is the amazing
Allah actually you are you are you are
amazing mall so sister repeat after me
one second let's get let's get the wi
camera let's get the whole team here we
want to witness this we want to witness
this no we want to witness this let's
get the ch
so sister repeat after me yeah we say it
we'll say the shahada we'll say the
shahada in English then we'll say it in
Arabic all right sister right
camera so come here I
testify I
testify that there is that there is no
one no one wory to be worshiped worthy
to be worshiped except Allah except
Allah and I testify and I
testify that
Muhammad that
Muhammad is the messenger is the
messenger of Allah of
Allah let's say it in Arabic yeah and I
will do my best to to say it too I will
I will do it slowly for
youu
Allah
Allah ASU
ASU
muhamad
ruu Allah
Allah aldah we are happy we are honored
having an amazing sister like yourself
and I will tell you something you you
know sister I will tell you something
what amazes me that Allah in Ramadan
there is every single night of Ramadan
Allah the prophet sallallah alaihi
wasallam will free people from the
punishment of the hell and Grant them
Jenna and actually this is the first
night of Ramadan or the second night of
Ramadan and which is the first day after
fasting and Allah has honored us firstly
having you as a sister for us and
because look how much you are good to
your to your husband how much you are
good to him you wanted to help him to
implement his faith properly that's why
Allah looked into your heart and found
you a genuine person that found that you
are wanted to help not just only you is
about about yourself it's about as well
your husband look how Beauty it is
that's why sister Allah has honored you
and us by you accepting Islam may Allah
bless you Sister
actually I was about
to because they seriously sister to see
an amazing Someone Like You who's Keen
to help her husband I was amazed these
things is not happening you don't find
this you don't find someone who has a
different Faith a wife has a different
faith and helping her husband because
you believed in inside you you believ it
is the truth but Allah brought you
eventually Allah brought you and I will
add your information the the companion
women came to the prophet peace be upon
him and then they said to him oh of
Allah we see the men they do this they
do they do different things what's for
us he said s wasallam he said if the
woman prayed her five daily prayer
fasted the month of Ramadan was good to
her husband Allah will say to her in the
day of judgment you enter paradise and
choose any gate that you want to enter
paradise and you already there so that's
why now alhamdulillah sto learning how
to pray stop fasting the month of
Ramadan joining your husband yes and
in we are very privileged having you
what's Erin what's your husband's name
is it Erin yes he's the um uh what did
you call him
um the no one second is is your is your
is your um one second yes oh is this one
second one second is this is this Erin
one second we just realized is this Erin
the one you've been teaching how to pray
Salah uh yes he's Erin oh my gosh one
second is this is it that bro one second
so this is guys this is profound this is
Erin the wood is the wood is his
instructor D has been teaching him how
to pray Salah so this is his wife yeah
okay so D Viking brother so this brother
so guys just just imagine this yeah so
this is literally happening real in
front of you so we talk about Salah
instructors and people don't really
understand D Muhammed and others this
instructors yeah we didn't even know
this yeah D has been teaching a brother
and he talks so highly of him Erin this
Erin that Erin we're like okay that
would we understand and he's just now
he's a beautiful brother he's like this
you know and Subhan Allah where we don't
even know because we can't see his face
it's his wife who's accepting Islam say
that Aaron also talks about d uh that
he's a beautiful brother all the time
that I feel like I'm talking to
D masallah sister Allah bless you we was
going to say Erin you've got an amazing
wife you've got an amazing friend who's
also my friend yeah brother so Erin look
after your wife inah she's amazing may
Allah bless you Sister We're going to
get in contact with you our sister's
team inshallah to help teach you how to
pray Salah sister inshah and we will
send you one of these guided prayer mass
as well or you can borrow your husbands
or borrow your husband I want my own
please
okay we're going to send you your own
guided prayer mat and not only that
we're going to get our sister's team
sister Huda inshah to contact you and
teach how to pray inshallah unless you
want your husband to get the reward no
no both both of them reward it's fine
that sounds very very good I am you my
heart is uh very very swollen right now
and I
just if praying Salah before is better
than this world and everything in it
then what is the reward for the one who
not only taught them how to pray Salah
but also the first chapter in the
Quran what if I told you that because of
your donations we will be teaching
thousands of people around the world to
learn how to pra Salah brothers and
sisters we only need 100 people to give
£100 £100 can help teach 10 to 30 people
learn how to praise Salah and memorize
Al fa for the first time ever imagine
you are the reason for people like
Michael like Katrina like Trisha like me
who learn how to to pray for the first
time ever with us thanks to your
donations the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alai wasallam said anyone
that calls someone to good will get the
same reward without anything being taken
away from them click the link below and
donate
[Music]
now